good morning falesha
over to you Michael Jordan every day the
first person there before the Sun would
be Jordan and he was there because he
wasn't good he would work with a batting
instructor and work all day long and be
the last person to leave every night
also as to what it was like for him the
morning and Jordan said I get up before
the Sun comes up and I make myself some
breakfast by myself he was down there
alone and I get in the car and I'm
driving to spring training and there's
no one really out on the roads yet and I
look at the seat next to me and I see my
dad and I talked to him I think to
myself pops we're doing this we're doing
this together and the day would end and
he would say to the batting instructor
point do a little more I think I'm
getting this I think I'm learning this I
think I'm
and that's when Sports Illustrated put
him on the cover saying that Michael
Jordan is embarrassed baseball and as I
would watch him there every night as the
Sun was going down on the other ball
players had left and I would see this
guy working to get better Michael Jordan
working to get better I couldn't help
thinking that if you ever have children
you ought to pray to take her up someday
where she like this so I love this clip
because Michael Jordan worked hard and
he brought that to everything he did
whether it was baseball whether it was
basketball or anything else he was
working on and I love it because if you
have a goal then you owe it to yourself
to give it your best you owe it to
yourself to really try and not feel like
you know if I gave that an extra day or
an extra week or an extra month a couple
months maybe maybe I would have had
success maybe it would be possible you
don't want to live with that regret what
you want to get is to an answer you know
Michael Jordan he didn't make it as a
baseball player but it wasn't because of
lack of effort
the dude tribe as you saw and if it
doesn't work out for your business and
you're meant to go do something else and
you're launching another company or even
if you go back get a job that's okay but
you want to know right I want to know if
I try something I want to know whether
this thing is gonna work out or not and
I don't want to live and regret for the
rest of my life so the key is to work
hard give it your all I do that every
day with my business today is that my
birthday I don't know when this videos
going live but May 20th is my recording
day it's my birthday and we can easily
come up with excuses right I can come
with the excuse to say well it's my
birthday so I'm not going to record any
videos or you know so my family is sick
so I'm not gonna record videos or you
know it's such a great summer day today
so I'm not gonna record videos we can
always cope with excuses for not working
hard and important things that we need
to do to make our businesses grow so
work hard be consistent give it your all
live life with no regrets and believe my
question is that today is I want to know
what your biggest regret is I want to
know something that happened in your
life and business of
professional life where you wish you had
given more of yourself to it what your
biggest regret is leave it in the
comments below I'm curious to find out
thank you guys so much for watching to
have an amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events preso